welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and thor 4 aka thor love and
thunder
we'll begin production real soon with
natalie portman confirming that jane
foster will be
fully following the mighty thor comics
writer director taika watiti said he's
basing the story on
revealing that jane foster in her words
is going through cancer treatment and
is a superhero on the side this is a
huge deal that confirms
why jane foster wields mjolnir in this
movie the love in love and thunder
i guess also the thunder in love thunder
thor granting his past
love a way to temporarily escape
exhaustive cancer treatments as a
superhero
but the big mystery we've been talking
about with this film is mjolnir itself
canonically in the mcu mjolnir is
shattered hella destroyed it in ragnarok
thor got it back from the past and end
game cap wielded it
but then cap returned it to the past
along with the stones
and that leaves us in the present mcu
with zero mjolnirs now we have discussed
possible explanations like thor 4 being
set in an alternate reality after one
division splits the mcu
into a multiverse a reality where
mjolnir remains
intact and thor and jane are still
together another explanation the
overlooked easter egg and infinity war
the possibility of a
backup mjolnir with the secondary forge
visible in the background on nitavalire
molten uru flowing into a different one
of ichri's forges
which is weird because all the necessary
pieces to make stormbreaker came from
that first forge
aside from the handle of course but that
would be wooden which
is how groot's arm came to serve as that
handle
and it is this moment i want to focus on
as we look ahead to thor 4
because earlier this year vin diesel
confirmed that groot
and maybe some of the other guardians of
the galaxy will appear in this next thor
film
now yeah groot will forever be at thor's
side technically in the form of the
handle of stormbreaker but there is a
lot we don't know about this weapon
its powers are over expansive its magic
definitely different from mjolnir's it's
technically more powerful than all six
infinity stones combined
and i believe there is actually a secret
groot related reason that this weapon is
gonna be more pivotal to thor's future
than we realize
let us investigate this god killer with
another episode of the
weapons of marvel
okay the most controversial aspect of
stormbreaker is that it possesses the
powers of the bifrost allowing
instant teleportation from and to
anywhere in the universe that's
a serious upgrade considering in the
thor movies control over that bifrost
bridge was
everything the bifrost was the nexus of
utrecil
the asgardian world's tree which
branches out to the nine realms
heindall and his staff were the lock and
key to that bridge
that's why they were so important to
loki and thor one and hella in ragnarok
but asgard's destruction and heimdall's
death felt so devastating
because we all briefly thought well [ __ ]
no more bifrost well [ __ ]
now the only way to teleport across the
galaxy is the space stone and thanos has
got it but then
e tree changed the game again with a
simple line about the dwarven magic that
went into stormbreaker's design the
king's weapon
meant to be the greatest in asgard in
theory it could even summon the bifrost
ah and so once they forge that weapon
thor groot rocket
ride that pie frost right into battle on
earth which was
nuts because now if you think about it
brings up questions like why didn't thor
use stormbreakers by for us to teleport
to wherever the hell tony stark was
marooned i mean i'm guessing it's
because captain marvel just got there
first
but it should not have taken a few weeks
thor was getting fat on beer and sweet
rolls while letting his buddy tony
suffer a thinner curse
this bifrost upgrade is compounded by
the fact that unlike mjolnir there is
no worthiness charm on stormbreaker
anyone can lift it
well not anyone that shit's heavy the
awesome team over at man at arms
estimated it would be around 400 pounds
we were gonna make that thing solid we
wouldn't even be able to pick it up we'd
probably have a 400 pound piece when we
were done
still no incantation from odin that
makes it so that only those who are
worthy can lift it the way mjolnir can
only be lifted by thor volt and cap
and hella and vision and a coffee table
and a coat hanger
we're pissing off odin here but if you
watch closely in end game thanos was
able to lift a stormbreaker he bore the
weight of stormbreaker a few times
redirecting it against thor and later
you'll notice
thor hooked mjolnir against the handle
of stormbreaker in order to weigh
both down and put thanos in a headlock
because stormbreaker alone couldn't do
that but there's one more interesting
element to throw breaker that i got to
bring up it came up the moment thor
summoned it past carol danvers at the
beginning of end game
[Music]
yeah we brought this up before but in
the audio mix many listeners do hear the
whispered phrase
i have telepathy
this can probably be explained as thor
just exhaling plus the power of
suggestion like i tell you to listen for
i have telepathy and now you can't hear
anything but i have telepathy and yeah
when director joe russo was asked if
this was carol danvers telepathically
sane eye telepathy he shot it down
but to be fair the exact
wording posed to him was did captain
marvel
tell thor i have telepathy russo was not
asked if someone else whispered that to
thor
i'm kidding i'm kidding i don't think
this is really evidence of anything and
i just think it's interesting
except it is kind of psychic magic that
thor uses to summon stormbreaker he
telepathically beckons it to his hand
and it
telekinetically responds which is just
creepy when you consider that this
weapon
possesses divine magic the bifrost comes
from the
all fathers the norse mythological
spiritual force from the heavens that
odin is now a part of
stormbreaker was able to cut through a
blast of the infinity stones including
the mind stone a gem that was said to
possess a
cosmic wisdom essentially stormbreaker
played instant chess with the mind stone
checkmated it and then punched the time
clock in thanos chest
and yes stormbreaker's handle is the
zombie arm of
groot and here's where i'm gonna do my
best to lose you
again the voice of groot itself
confirmed groot will return in thor 4
but in what form well diesel hinted that
groot would evolve
i only have two words
uh about that character and it is
alpha group what does alpha group mean
are we talking size or something else
well remember thor never actually says
the name groot he calls them by a
different name
oh by the way this is a friend of mine
tree i
am real i am steve rogers he calls them
tree in in game he calls them tree again
when they reunite
well here we are trees good to see you
there says that over a close-up of his
bag
which thuds on that table indicating it
contains
stormbreaker this is all coming together
because i now suspect there to be
possible truth to the theory
one that you or others might have
wondered that stormbreaker's buy frost
magic and its handle's origin from groot
whom thor calls
tree could lead to a groot evolution
into an alpha
and omega form the handle growing
into the new asgardian yidrasil world's
tree think about it as a weapon
stormbreaker was tailored uniquely for
thanos and the infinity stones
mission accomplished now it's just too
powerful and plot hole inducing to leave
in the universe like this
and with mjolnir returning in thor 4
stormbreaker must serve a new purpose
especially with rumored villains like
gore the god butcher coming after thor
now
you don't want gore to get his hands on
stormbreaker so to disarm that weapon
its 4g must be reversed it's got to be
dismantled creating that branch arm of
groot
allowing it to be replanted in new
asgard
in the soil of the cliffside grave of
odin the all father
the foundation of the new bifrost bridge
the new asgardian utrecil
the bifrost powered tree that branches
back out to the nine realms a tree
binding all of us within a simple truth
we are groot
subscribe to new rockstars hit that
notification bell follow me on instagram
eaboss follow new rockstars thanks for
watching we are boom
[Music]
you